i'm just thinking about how spooky it's
getting in the world because it's
halloween time
you know it's halloween man halloween
uh man i still love do you remember
halloween
remember remember how much fun dude
remember remember how much fun you had
remember how much fun you had
halloween what are you gonna be what are
you gonna be for like couple of weeks
when you were in like elementary school
middle school what are you gonna be what
are you gonna be
i'm gonna be a princess i'm gonna be
a coal miner you know i'm gonna be a
firefighter
that was always a big one i'm gonna be a
firefighter
you know when it was just like a and and
the costumes used to be way more normal
wait like oh daniel is a bat oh that's
good job daniel you know
lawrence is um he's a coal miner
in a wheelchair oh good job lawrence
selina is pregnant oh
that's interesting but way to go selena
you know you just you see that little
girl she come in the door she you know
she just that's her idea of what of
creativity she's seven years old she got
a pillow in her
you know and lipstick on you like okay
she's
you know maybe seeing a little too much
at the house you know
but that was that was that was then that
was that was halloween
and then i remember you would get the
candy
and i always like them snickers than
baby snickers
you know out here in in los angeles they
give all you know
the costumes are you know out here it's
not even a
it's not even know you know it's like uh
jackson is a hashtag
uh lorenzo well he refuses to dress up
this year because
he believes that uh halloween is you
know it's
it's not fair to ghosts like actual
ghosts aren't getting the credit they
deserve
yeah well [ __ ] that bruh halloween is a
great opportunity
to get an empty bag or anything empty
did i remember one time
running around our neighborhood with a
plant pot
because it just seemed like the biggest
thing around
fill it up i didn't care what you put in
it
dude i remember one got us poured half
of a beer out in the mine i'm like yeah
dude i love getting them little snickers
and i love putting on my costume you
look i found these sounds remember
listen to these halloween mask sounds
okay these were sounds that your mask
made maybe when you put the mask on all
right here we go
[Applause]
remember that okay now what about this
one listen to this one
[Applause]
oh that now if you had some money the
second one you had a little bit of money
because they had that hard
that plastic it was like getting back in
your in
in your mother's womb just
[Music]
once you go whatever that and that thing
was always like a wool for like a
you know a donkey head or a
you know it could be anything it would
be but it was something like severe like
a big
lizard head if you got into that thing
you weren't
that was it for the night i didn't like
those things because i always felt
trapped you know i remember one time
being in a costume and i couldn't get
that thing off
man and i could see out of the
eyes and i could see the world like so
clearly but
no one could hear me because the plastic
was too thick
so i quit talking to people and it was
sweaty
and it was scary because i couldn't like
my peripheral vision was gone so i
couldn't see around me that good
and i could just see and it was just
like i was watching the world happen a
little bit more
and i thought for a second i honestly i
thought that was like i wonder if this
is what it feels like to have like
autism or
down syndrome you know like you're in
there and you can
see like it all seems really really
clear
but you're like sweating and
and uh and you and you can't
and people can't hear you or you can't
like communicate as well because
you know you got on these you know you
got so much
extra on you you know
remember that getting into that one this
is another one there's one more sound
here we go
that's kind of similar similar one but
yeah halloween
man halloween and you would run bro you
would have that candy
dude i remember this i wanted candy so
bad i remember
grabbing like my wiener and just
squeezing it
that's how bad i wanted candy
and i wanted that snicker man every time
i wanted that snicker that's exactly
give me this or do they have the snicker
no
somebody had a sucker what is that
[ __ ] i'll get that at the bank i'll get
that
at a dang at a
at a bank i'll get that at a whitney
bank that's what they used to have in
louisiana that whitney bank
it's crazy man it was so much fun
dude and i remember my mom had that
station wagon
and the station wagon dude you could
hide in the old school
now they got these little subaru legacy
you know we had we had the station wagon
this thing was that world war ii hitter
i'm saying if you got far enough into
the back you could hear soldiers
fighting
that [ __ ] that fifth ru you know the
they had the back seat then they had
this big extra
long area that was straight up dunkirk
back there
people were losing their lives back
there
and my mama they had the the station
wagon
had a um it had a thing it dropped down
you know because this is when i was this
is when i was probably let me think
five okay or six and they had that that
the station wagon had a back
thing it was a like a tailgate
it was a tailgate and we just dropped
down it was heavy bruh
if you if it came down you you didn't
put it back up until maybe
springtime or until a different time of
year you know it was that thing was
heavy
and we would all get on there and hang
we would all get up we'd stand on there
and be all dressed up in our costumes
you know everybody would be keyed up
and just you know somebody would be uh
um
somebody would just be like i'm a i'm a
like a a a bloody ghost and they would
just
you know have blood all over them and
maybe have a bed sheet kind of tied
around
them they actually just looked like a
greek person that had been you know in a
domestic dispute
you know you'd have some horrible
[ __ ] costumes
you know now it's a little bit more like
the parents dress the kids i feel like
when i when i was young you dre dude
i'm you just you know i remember you put
a little bit of dirt on you
like i'm uh i'm a um piece of facade you
know you put a little bit of
you know maybe some grass in your hair
but it was fun man we'd all get on the
back of that we'd get on the back of
mom's station wagon and she let us stand
on the tailgate
she let us stand on the tailgate because
i lived in america
in the 90s and you could stand on the
tailgate and you could hold on to the
top of the station wagon
and mom would drive around the rich
people's neighborhood
and i'd be on the back at admin
just waiting you'd see a house where it
looked like they had somebody sitting
out front like a senior citizen or
something
you know a in a rocking chair and they
were all dressed up and
they you know they had like um maybe
some decorations
like oh these mother has got that
snicker
these the people that got the snicker
because when i was young that's all you
wanted man
some people during halloween they were
giving out the little they used to have
these black these candies they were like
it was just a it was kind of like
somebody had tried
they were orange and black the it was
just
wrapped up and it was barely wrapped up
some of the candy was kind of leaking
out the back end you know
some of the candy had a little bit of
side boob kind of you know a little
brown kind of side boob popping out of
the um
they're wrapping you know these little
candies they came in little wrappers
little
you know little blankets little duffel
bags for candies
you know rappers rappers and
and they would give you these and it was
chewy it was chunk you didn't even it
was
it was un it was the unknown candy
it was like the tomb of the unknown
diabetes it was just a chunk of
you were like oh is this chocolate is it
caramel
is it apple and you would just eat it
and by the time you even kind of maybe
had an idea what it was it was gone
and you had no idea what it was and it
was actually
absolutely just nothing just garbage
straight up
just that i mean it was i mean it could
have been a polio vaccine i have no clue
what it was
i mean it could have been i just
remember it got your sugar up and got
you amped up to go another couple
blocks you know and i remember a couple
of them if you had two or three of the
orange ones in a row you couldn't turn
your neck for a little bit
that [ __ ] would get my neck all tight
make my veins really start
you know make my veins kind of dance
together and kind of get to know each
other a little bit maybe even doing
you know make it make you feel like your
neck didn't want if
your neck would get tight if i had too
many of them little
because they were just unknown candies
they didn't have a name to them
they were cheap and they just it was
just enough to get you that next house
and see if they had a little thing of
smarties bruh rich people always had
smarties
or you know it little snickers
dog you on halloween bruh
dude i would train all month in october
at the house stretching
you know fighting my getting beat up by
my brother
you know pissing my mom off let her hit
me with that leather
because i was gonna be ready for october
31st
when daddy little daddy hit the night
time
for thought was about to rock way
solo joe hit the night time
going looking for that snicker and they
call me and they see me
they see me and they know i'm hunting
that snekka
and i'd be out there and we'd be on the
back of mom's uh and i've told this
story
i probably told it last halloween i'd be
on the back we'd all be lined up on the
back of us one of us
you know somebody's just easy easy easy
costumes
somebody's a turtle you know little
ronald's a turtle
you know little uh daniel he's a um
he's a goat and he got real goat hair
his dad put real
honey and goat hair on his back to make
him look authentic
and he's a real little goat boy and they
put little fake horns on his head you
know
and and they squeezed him maybe into a
um
they might have squeezed him into a mask
i don't even know they might have
squeezed in one of those tight hitters
and little fanuls all keyed up
and maybe they even maybe his daddy had
a little bit extra time off of work
in october and he put real wood on the
bottom of his shoes
and he any any and he nailed it into the
bottom of his shoes or
or or super glued it onto the bottom and
painted it black
so now little daniel got real hoofs
and he you know maybe he's out there and
you have on um you know children's
underwears or
uh you know or uh even sometimes in
halloween you put on a baby diaper
you put a diaper on your body you know
in case you wanted a piss or something
because you wouldn't
you know we went hard at halloween there
wasn't and we was in
we were on enemy territory we're out
there trick-or-treating by the rich
do you trick-or-treat in my neighborhood
do you get probably
you get a rash for sure bed bugs
you get probably i mean they have
registered a lot of registered sex
offenders by us
so you know none of these freelance boys
i'm talking people in the union
you know them real hitters so you
wouldn't really
you know a lot of people advised then
you have calendars you stop by dressed
up
you know they might think you're a real
animal if you come by little thing
you'll rolls up as a goat bro they might
[ __ ] grill that boy up
you know we having a little bit of we
having some rack of daniel
back here uh next weekend we having a
barbecue
but yeah man we would go and daniel
would have he'd have maybe real goat
hair on him
you know his dad would put honey on the
back of his legs and honey on his back
and then they had real goats so they'd
get real hair off these goats
because that's free if you have goats
that hair is yours if they're cool with
it
and you put it on and then you're like
damn that boy looks [ __ ]
he's a real swaggy piece out here
and we'd all be on the back of the and
we'd have those diapers on because we
weren't going back home
you know what i'm saying if you if
the diaper was because if you wanted a
urinator or you know
or make duty and you could do it right
there and still trick or treat
because this was our this was our
vietnam bruh
october 31st it was us
against the world it was us against
these candy makers and these people
where they had front doors
and these people that had
jack-o'-lanterns and it was us and we
was going to get ours we was going to
get them
then baby snicker and man it was epic
and we'd all be on the back of that
[ __ ] on the back of mom's car
with that with that uh with the tailgate
down and she's rolling
bro she's cruising because she's pissed
because my mother was
always pissed think about a time
when my mother has been alive she was
pissed then
i promise you and we're on the back and
mom would roll up by the yard and we
would run and jump off that tailgate
into the yard
as that car was going just
like out right out the back of a c-130
man shout out to all of our service men
and women just
just right out in the yard and tumble
roll into the yard
lose half your [ __ ] candy in the roll
what whatever
onward onward
hold the line forward
and we'd roll out onto the ground you
know your brother
and then your sister would come off at
the last minute she only two years old
and the [ __ ] in that mom car still
rolling just coming to a stop
and my sister just fell all off that
[ __ ] she couldn't even jump
her legs didn't have that jump ability
in them yet they was just
you know just them [ __ ] little
pushers she would just kind of push
herself and then just fall
and she'd fall right off the tailgate
into whoever's yard it was some rich
person's yard
and then it was just every step you
could get through the dark grass to get
up to that
front door and you would just
ring that damn bell you would knock
dude i would ring and then knock and if
they weren't there within half of a
second
i would ring again
and you would fight over who got to say
trick-or-treat remember that
cut rolling up close to the door you
have it you have a six-minute fist fight
over who gets to say trick-or-treat
and then you get there and you and then
they open it up
and sometimes inside you see people
having fun
families you know maybe they're watching
tv or tickling each other
maybe the dad if he's rich he might be
throwing a piece of popcorn up in the
air
catching in his mouth you know maybe the
kid you see you got a nice pair of cl
you know
extra shoes or cleats by the door
whatever they got calendars you know
legitimate calendars from this
this from the actual year it was on the
wall
and then and then and the mom is right
there and she got the big bowl and she's
dressed up like a um little cat
or like a uh you know a female
lemur or something kind of sexy you know
like a little deer
and [ __ ] she got that bowl and man you
hope that snicker was in there
god i loved halloween and then it was on
to the next one
and you make the street and then there
weren't as many you know you didn't see
as many porch lights on you'd be like
all right let's get back on the car
let's get back on mom's tailgate go mom
and mom's complaining is everybody who
gives a go
go
you're back there yelling bro half your
candy you don't even know you
point you getting your brother to look
at something stealing half of his [ __ ]
you got all the candy bags tied around
your sister's neck she's at this point
she's just a sugar mule
she's just mule and sweets around yes
you know she's two years old building up
thighs she
you know by by the end of halloween
night by november 1st she got thighs
looked like a damn quarter horse
looked like a pony that was raised in
quicksand
and is still alive she got them big
strong thighs
and she just got nine bags of candy tied
around her
and she just mule and sugar and you guys
back on the tailgate again you're going
and you see another person's yard and
we'd run and we jump off
and i'll never forget what happened man
lilthaniel
jumped off and some people every now and
then
some some real f
fuckeroo has to have a hydrant
in the front of their yard
and you know what's great about them
they don't put lights around the hydrant
they don't put any it's just a a hydrant
in the front of the yard and this person
had painted their hydrant brown
so it would match their house what a
real
albert stein
so we all running off we jump into the
yard one
two three just parachuting off the back
of mom's tailgate and little daniel
a little daniel that little goat boy you
know he's all shook up he's hopped
up he's had maybe about [ __ ] 65 rolls
of smarties
and 15 of those you know unidentifiable
brown and black candies
he got so much he and those things you
couldn't even get them it would just get
stuck
in your teeth remember that remember
those can't and that's all they were
those things the orange and black ones
they just get all it was
was something that kind of tasted like
coffee and would get stuck in your teeth
come on but little daniel bro he'd run
it jumped off
and in the dark you thought it was yard
because we'd all hit yard
and daniel [ __ ] just just landed
right into that um
the fire hydrant just i just imagine
flying through the air halloween on your
brain
65 rolls of smarties in your system
hopped up
won't be able to close your eyes for a
month you got so much glucose
rolling through you you got
real honey hooked goat hair
on your back your daddy made you [ __ ]
wooden hooves
you got pine hooves nailed into the
bottom of your reeboks and you got on a
diaper full of
urine and possibly number two depends on
how fired up you were
and you got a [ __ ] damn goat mask on
your face
and out of nowhere just bam
out of the pitch black a fire hydrant
you jump off of a tailgate end of pure
darkness
and you hit a fire hydrant
and that boy was never the same
never the same so
but that's halloween man
god i love it and i miss it and i'm
happy to be here man
crazy but different back in the day
people you could dress up as an apple
you know an an indian we
had a black kid came on our door as an
indentured servant
like whatever people didn't care if he
wasn't like oh this means this this mean
whatever
this a kid they want to dress up let
them dress up
you know i you know i i people know i've
been peppermint pat before
and i'll get a you know a cotton you
know some cotton
body cover and stuff and you know shirts
and that and pants
and i put little peppermints all over
them and people are like who are you and
i'm like i'm peppermint pet
and they're like who is that and i'm
like who
it's no one it's peppermint pat
you know what i'm saying i'm that breast
you know
i'm that bit i'm that i'm that sugary
little
freshener i'm that sugary fresh and i'll
put you know my finger i put two
you know i brush my hands along your
along your cheeks
and make your breath smell nice
peppermint pat not a real person but in
my mind it was real
remember halloween was also a chance i
remember it was a chance to go
door-to-door in your neighborhood
and see what the [ __ ] was going on
remember that you get to some people's
house you're like damn they don't have
any
furniture
i remember we opened one one person
opened the door it's just a garage their
whole house was just a garage
like what are y'all y'all sleeping in
that ford explorer
the hell is going on
but you kind of got to see what was
going on in different people's lives man
it was interesting it was really really
interesting
um but happy early halloween i'm excited
you know i get excited for the holidays
and i get excited
you know i love the holidays you know i
love things that bring people together
and i think that the holidays is one of
those things and
and i think we all need it i think we
all need it
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
good afternoon and other times thanks
for watching that video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one